ja wir wollen direkt nach rheinland
pfalz schauen denn nach der brutalen
hinrichtung zweier junger polizisten
meldet sich nun die ministerpräsidentin
des bundeslandes zu wort malu dreyer
spricht am rhein
seit der tat aber heute wir an diesem
tag geht es um 10 uhr eine gedenk minute
geben und alle polizeidienststellen die
schulen viele einrichtungen werden
gedenken an die beiden jungen
polizeibeamten beamtinnen die so grausam
ermordet worden sind auch ganz
deutschland trauert es ist kaum sich
vorzustellen wie aufgewühlt die polizei
familie ist es gibt eine große
solidarität untereinander
diese grausame tat weist die polizei
familie noch stärker zusammen als sie
ohnehin als polizei familie zusammen
steht wir sind heute hier der
innenminister und ich um den angehörigen
den freunden freundinnen der polizei
kollegen und kolleginnen das mitgefühl
der gesamten landesregierung
auszudrücken und noch einmal deutlich zu
machen wie stark unser mitgefühl ist ich
bin hier sehr bewusst darüber dass worte
in einer solchen situation kaum trösten
können ich kann nur hoffen dass sich die
angehörigen die freunde die kollegen und
kolleginnen
dass sie in ihrer großen in ihrem leid
in ihrer trauer spüren das ganz ganz
viele zusammen stehen und mit ihnen
fühlen und mit ihnen trauern der rest
der hashtag
eine zwei von uns ist ein hashtag unter
dem sich ganz viele aus der polizei
familie verbinden und deutlich machen
wie stark ihre trauer und ihr mitgefühl
ist wir haben den verlust zu verrückt zu
beklagen zwei junge menschen die alten
nach allem was ich geschildert bekommen
habe lebensfrohe junge menschen waren
eine junge polizeikommissaranwärterin
und ein polizeioberkommissar die das
ganze leben noch vor sich hatten die
fröhliche kollegen und kolleginnen waren
die stolz waren bei der polizei zu sein
die einfach mit großem optimismus in die
zukunft geschaut haben es ist einfach
nur schrecklich und traurig und es ist
nicht verwunderlich dass das mitgefühl
und die trauer überall sehr sehr stark
und groß ist zum abschluss will ich noch
sagen wir erleben im netz gerade
widerwärtige dinge dass diese tat von
manchen bejubelt wird das ist einfach
nur menschenverachtend und schlimm umso
wichtiger ist es dass das lka sehr
schnell gehandelt hat und mit einer
eigens eingesetzten gruppe gegen hate
speech vorgeht im netz wir werden nichts
dergleichen dulden wir stehen hinter und
vor unserer polizei wir werden weder
beleidigung noch drohungen dulden und
werden sehr klar immer
verfolgen nicht nur löschen sondern
verfolgen wir werden bestraft und alle
mittel des rechtsstaates nutzen um das
tatsächlich dann auch zur strafe zu
bringen
ja soweit die ministerpräsidentin von
rheinland pfalz malu dreyer diese tat
und auch das motiv lassen ein wirklich
fassungslos zurück die mutmaßlichen
polizisten killer waren wilderer die
wohl ihre beute schützen wollten um 10
uhr da wird es bundesweit eine
schweigeminute geben bereits gestern gab
es einen wirklich bewegenden
trauergottesdienst
deutschland nimmt abschied von zwei
helden polizeianwärterin jasmin b und
oberkommissar alexander kahr wurden am
ersten februar brutal hingerichtet
dieser doppelmord shop ganz deutschland
die bluttat von kusel wird noch lange in
erinnerung bleiben
am abend um 19 uhr 30 evangelische
kirche in kusel
[Musik]
die gemeinde und kollegen der
verstorbenen gedenken der opfer die
stimmung ist gedrückt die trauer ist
groß in diesen stunden
für mich sind das niedrige beweggründe
die mich erschüttern tiefst zutiefst
erschüttern der mich den glauben an die
menschheit
zweifeln lässt dass so etwas passieren
kann wir leben hier im landkreis derzeit
eine unheimliche betroffenheit
zutiefst schockiert
einfachen erfassung diese brutale tat
ist so unvorstellbar dass wir alle
zusammenhalten müssen ganz klar uns auch
bekennen müssen zur polizei zu unseren
ordnungskräften wachtmeister rinnen
wachtmeister sind schutz leute die
draußen auf der straße unterwegs sind
und für unser aller sicherheit sorgen
und wenn dann jemand auf so tragische
weise das leben genommen kriegt und dann
zerreißt es allem das herz ich habe am
montag die nachrichten gelesen war
wirklich erschüttert so etwas grausames
konnte ich mir nie vorstellen aber
passiert ich bin der meinung
polizeigewalt in deutschland hat so
zugenommen ganz schlimm deutschland hat
meiner meinung kein problem mit polizei
gewalt sondern mit gewalt gegen die
polizei das sollte man dringend etwas
unternehmen ich bin erschüttert man
kennt die kollegen die hier bei der
polizei sind die menschen in kusel sind
bis ins mark erschüttert es ist ein
abschied für immer von diesen beiden
jungen menschen die jetzt nicht mehr
unter uns sind
[Musik]